joining me here on the rich eisen show
for the first time as a solo act on this
program we last had him on when the
actor john schneider from dukes of
hazard fame was on and we had this man
call him but now this is just it's just
him he's running this show like he runs
the seattle seahawks john schneider the
general manager here on the program how
are you john
[Music]
good rich how are you guys doing i hope
you're feeling better
we are appreciate uh you doing this man
i appreciate your your sentiments and um
i i know you don't do this
is bow going to be honest no there's no
duke and by the way there's no hazard
this is all it's all green lights here
man we're all green lights and
let's let's hop in this car and start
driving it and having a good time let's
go uh let's get right into like let's
let's start talking about you signing
the prez who's one of my favorite people
uh in the nfl jamal adams walk me
through that process and you uh you uh
bestowing him with the seemingly richest
contract in his safety for safety in the
nfl john schneider
well it's awesome we're glad to get it
done uh you know we traded for him last
year we we we promised him that uh you
know before we made the trade that we'd
we'd extend them in the off season and
uh
you know it was a long process but at
the end of the day we we got there
everybody's extremely excited and and uh
yeah he's a very unique player as you
know uh
guy can rush the passer and extremely
explosive just brings a huge energy
and uh great for the locker room great
for the building uh you know he was here
he was treating our staff great
uh working with the coaches and
everything as we uh we're trying to
negotiate a deal yeah i mean he plays
everywhere i mean you just don't know
where he's going to wind up and he's in
the backfield almost as much as he's in
the secondary and uh you know i i i love
the guy i i really do you know i've
grown up in new york city and
he's a locker room guy that can change a
culture obviously you don't need that
but you can use his energy in a certain
way and it's it's a w all around as far
as yeah you can feel it already actually
regimen he's had two days out here where
he's just been you know extremely
excited obviously and um you know just
with the players just been been great so
yeah we're excited to get that done so
uh what what does a general manager do
middle of the preseason like what is
your what is your day like i know i i
know you laugh but i i i want to know
exactly where you are with roster cuts
and rosters and looking around the
league and walk me through what the
process is like for somebody like
yourself you're 12 i believe right as
the gm of of the seahawks what is this
like yeah yeah yeah so really for us you
know it's it's all about every day
you know how do we improve you know when
we always talk about winning the day
right so how we're going to get better
every single day our staff now we have
we have games this year we have one
pre-season weekend in um you know we had
the first hall of fame game but
uh which gets overscouted more than
another game in in nfl history by the
way all the time because it's just one
game but uh no we we have all of our
guys that uh on our staff here we have a
great we have great personnel staff and
and uh just studying our team every day
and studying um other other teams
weaknesses uh strengths
and uh communicating with other teams
and seeing if we can um you know work on
trades and who may be available at the
uh 53 cut this year is a little bit
unique because we have the three games
and and we cut down five after the first
two
and then we go to uh then we go to 53
from there but having the 16 practice
squad players really really helps us and
and so
uh it's really kind of what we're doing
is is studying our team every day and
then trying to create a landscape for
the whole season and when i say that i
mean what does december look like what
does november look like in order to add
depth at specific positions and
uh provide the coaches and uh with with
the top you know what we believe are the
top players available and uh you have
meetings with pete about this i mean
walk me through that uh with with your
head coach yeah
yeah so pete and i talk about our team
every day pretty much and you know we'll
talk i mean we'll talk about everything
that's going on every position positions
we're concerned about we don't know we
don't have a level of complacency
obviously you've seen that over the
years rich we uh
uh we're constantly working at it um you
know we're
we're constantly talking about uh where
we can improve um
and you know as we talk about the draft
process we never feel like we have all
the answers so we always feel like that
improves our communication and and so
what you know what we look like on the
offensive line we look like a receiver
and you know if if this person and not
that that person so it's always kind of
creating this this this uh short-term uh
landscape for the coaches and then
long-term for the personnel staff so
that we can have people ready in in in
spots that uh where guys are ready to
take over it at any position if called
upon because you never know when you
know a rash of injuries are going to hit
you
john schneider general manager executive
vp of the seattle seahawks here on the
rich eisen show and you're you're kind
of a hyphenated guest too for me john
because we know a lot of people in
common
um right you're tight with my buddy jeff
shafer who's uh uh he's a hyphenate for
curb your enthusiasm and dave the the
show dave you know and so absolutely so
i hear from a lot of people here you
gotta have great guys he is a great guys
funny guy how come you haven't been in
curb yet he's still celebrating his 50th
birthday i think by the way but he's
it's it's like a lollapalooza we
understand that but you haven't you have
not been you have how come you haven't
been on curb how has that not happened
have you been on did i miss it
no have not have not i was on the league
which was a total blast for us because
you know when you play yourself as an
actor it's amazing i haven't got any
checks lately though so you got to give
them some credit about that
you haven't gotten your residuals i
still get something from my appearance
yeah yeah the last one was like 62
dollars i think it's a good one i'm like
you know where where are they at i know
that i love my wife's hiding them from
keeping them from me i don't know so not
only do we have we have similar you know
people in common but also um you're a
newsmaker um and you're you're somebody
in the nfl who can also you know help me
out with pete here i think i pissed him
off a little bit when he was on my show
uh-oh in the summer i don't know you
know i i i don't think i don't know if
you can i don't know if you can pick i
didn't know that you know what i got how
about this
how about this one a little bit okay i
might have rubbed him the wrong way a
couple times where i i brought up
russell i brought up russell wilson to
him and what russell was saying back in
the spring and he called it old news he
called it old news and i don't think he
really wanted me to bring it up or talk
because it was old news and i said yeah
but we haven't spoken since then and
then he allowed the answer so um i just
want to make sure pete and i are fine
because there was another time i kind of
i think i i might have rubbed him the
wrong way also
um which i'll get to he didn't say
anything to me about it so i think i
think you're
okay he would definitely so he would
definitely come to my office and discuss
it
i'm sure that's the top of his list we
know that what's going on
i i think he did
all right so i would say always all i
would say about all i would say about
that rich is that everything's
everything's great now i mean russ is
the guy that you know look
you know passionate people say
passionate things right and so at the
end of the season the thing that i've
told people you know behind closed doors
is
you know pete carroll and and uh and
russell wilson during a season don't
have the the um the ability to sit back
and evaluate you know the big picture
like uh the rest of us do and so you
know it's our job it's my job in
particular to be in in our staff to be
looking at what's coming you know what's
happening in the future so what happens
is you know when you lose a game like we
lost to with the rams all sudden you
know these guys have been embedded every
single week on a schedule for how many
weeks you know throughout a season and
also it's like they kind of come up from
you know uh you know they're just like
they're just like waking up right
they're like wow what's not what do we
what do we what do we do now affects the
team how do we get better and so you
know uh ross is a you know extremely
hard worker extremely passionate guy he
wants to win a world championship every
single year like we do and we approach
our jobs like i said every day like we
want to be a consistent championship
caliber football team for our fans
because we feel like if if we're not
doing
the things to improve our team
um if you don't give your fans hope like
you know look i grew up in green bay and
so like there's many times like you know
i didn't see a winning team until i was
like
19 20 years old i think so um you know
you just i was always one of the packers
like whoever was working over there to
have this attitude like hey
you know
like what are we doing every single day
to get better and and how we're going to
improve and i think that's what you see
at the end of every season
um it's not just it's not just uh you
know uh russell or or pete it's it's
every organization
it's it's
a personnel staff has to kind of
incorporate with the coaches
uh you know where you're going and our
philosophy is that we've done it the
same way for
like you said 12 years now where
you know how we going to be a
competitive uh or how are we going to be
a consistent championship caller
football team every single year where
your fans are excited and so that's
that's what drives it and i think that's
what you saw now
was there a huge media blitz sure and uh
you know the best thing you can do you
know the guys that that taught me well
or just to sit back and listen and watch
and that's what we did well i mean part
of the narrative john schneider gm uh
and uh
uh executive vice president of the uh uh
the seattle seahawks joining me here on
the rich either show
part of the narrative john was also um
russ sitting there at the super bowl
where he just won the walter payton man
of the year award and well deserved
watching tom brady win it all and you
know in your old stomping grounds in
green bay the narrative is again a
quarterback who wants things a certain
way and believes that his say
should be louder in the room than it is
perceived to the player that was the
general sense of things you're a general
manager how do you view
the viewpoint of your star quarterback
in terms of
you know you doing your job and getting
the roster
as potentially the core
much like everybody else's i mean we're
wide open organization i mean really we
always talk about having no walls you
know we talked about that i work with
with organizations where you know the
personnel guys aren't allowed to talk to
the scouts and the personnel staff are
not allowed to talk to the to the
coaches on a daily basis or you know
some teams don't let their scouts go to
practice or you know that's not us we
all work together uh we have a great
staff downstairs with with uh
you know our player development people
and equipment and trainers and and our
sports science staff we just had a
really cool meeting yesterday where
we're talking everybody's talking about
what what can we do to help
everybody that's here you know improve
and so
with with that i would say you know yeah
you're definitely you're definitely
going to
be listening and and
taking everybody's opinions and
you know i look at it very much like you
know when we're preparing for the draft
and and
you know we go from having call it 30
people in the room to
you know
15 as we get closer to the draft to
10 and then a couple nights before the
draft it's just or like two nights
before the draft is just pete and i and
then
and then
the night before the draft it's just
myself so you're constantly listening
studying getting everybody's opinions
and
you know players guys especially that
are so passionate about studying like
like a bobby wagner and russell wilson
and they they watch so much film they're
in the mix you know they they can tell
you things that that other people can't
necessarily tell you that's like that's
why i like having you know former
players on our staff as well because
they can tell you you know certain
things that that we may not see or or
just you know where our blind spots are
another moment john schneiderlin that
doesn't mean you're always gonna that
doesn't mean you're always gonna agree
right so you know you listen you
communicate and you make you know at the
end of the day people have to make
decisions and you know my job is to
listen and and uh
you know work with work with pete and
and uh and keep steering this ship the
way we have another moment john
schneider i do believe uh pete bristled
when i brought up his i i i went there i
brought up his age you know because he
is as jim brockmeyer called what like
the world's youngest world's oldest
teenager is that what he called him the
world's oldest teenager now the dick
clark has no idea he had that now that
dick clark is no longer with us that's
what jim brockmeyer the famed uh
announcer said um i brought that up to
him and how much longer he wants to do
it and
and then i immediately regretted it
because i i heard it in his voice like
what are you trying to do rich is what
he said i think that's what he said
um what what
what what can you tell me about about
pete's long-term future
about working with him every day yes
it's been the same so he's 20 years
older than me
and he there are many days where i feel
like i'm 20 years older than him right
he is just a ball of energy his brain is
going a thousand miles an hour uh
enthusiastic positive uh
you know if you walk in he calls my
office the dentist office because i'll
have like smooth jazz on watercolors you
know trying to chill out and study and
listen to people try to get the stress
off right
he's going his office and it's like
you got you got me you got music playing
you got three different tvs going he's
studying film and he's trying to talk to
you at the same time and i always have
to say hey can you let's just can we
just mute this or turn this down because
i can't my brain my brain my brain does
not work like yours right but no he's
great man he he uh
he just keeps going and going and going
and
and
you wouldn't you you wouldn't know it
like my point like he's out there
throwing the football he's got a bad
shoulder he's throwing the ball like
like what are you doing man you know
he's just he's just awesome so he's he's
going to be the coach there for a long
time
john right like that i would thank i
would think you know
yeah
i have no reason not to think he
wouldn't be okay um before i let you go
i'd love a story about dk metcalf about
the first time he saw him
about um
anything i'm so fascinated by him
my kids can't get enough of him just
because not only because they they love
him on their fantasy teams but you know
the different hair color
um his choice of mouth guard i mean like
literally everything about him
is fascinating to young and old and i
would love a story right anything that
you could tell me about when you knew
you thought you knew uh anything i'll
give you the floor on that if you don't
mind
well yeah my son says he's hilarious on
instagram too i guess okay correct
the kids the kid the kids think he's
pretty awesome yeah
that's a good but uh
you know i would think um
i would think with him he was such a
an interesting study because he
absolutely blew up the uh
you know blew up the combine so he had
so much hype around him
um there were aspects of his game where
everybody you know kind of picked him
apart uh
our staff in particular was really
excited about you know just the pure
intangibles in his work ethic
i think you know
having his his father playing the league
there's a level of maturity about him
and so when uh you know when he was
still
available we made that move with with
the jets or the uh patriots excuse me to
go get him
and just i guess just to see the
you always want to have buy-in from from
the coaching staff when you make a
decision like that and so
you know we had a bunch of stuff going
on and and um pete was like well
he's like johnny we're on the clock
we're on the clock again i'm like yeah
we just we just traded with new england
we're gonna gonna we're gonna take we're
gonna take my calf right here and he's
like
my ass gonna be on our team
yeah yeah buddy we're gonna take metcalf
right here and then the whole room just
like exploded you know like he's like
hey guys we're taking back half we got
metcalf so i think
that excitement where you have the
buy-in from your coaching staff so um
you know usually you know you've seen
the clips where we call the guys all the
time and some guys are really excited
some guys aren't he was you know he was
very emotional um you know kind of
pissed obviously he wasn't taken earlier
but uh
i would say you know just like initially
that's that would be like a a a thought
that comes to my head or a story that
comes to my head about him because
uh having the buy-in from the coaches to
really want to work with this guy
and and try to help him be the best he
can possibly be well the first i saw him
was at the combine when he did jump out
of the building and run out of the
building and lift out of the building
and did all that but he also
i i believe it was his mom who he then
facetimed right away because of the neck
injury that that caused him to maybe
think that he's not going to have a
career and then his decision to leave
when he did with everybody questioning
whether he had was viable or not and he
crushed it at the combine and he got all
emotional i will never forget that
and then you know the story about what
apparently happened with the jim
schwartz you know before the game
in philadelphia where he said he
reminded him of calvin
that used that as fire to go torch them
uh he's just a totally
different
kind of player it seems to me
yeah and i'm sure you've seen the clip
of pete taking it
off
yeah yeah our uh our guy aaron heinlein
got got dk to take his shirt off for uh
pete to walk in the room because he
wanted us to draft him so bad so he came
walking in and pete was like oh he
smokes so pete took his shirt off that
was pretty fun moment too but uh you
know the guy the guy's really passionate
he works his tail off and and wants to
be great and yeah doesn't compare
himself to other people that's a
question that you know we always ask
guys so it's a standard like who do you
you know who do you who do you emulate
or whatever you know and he's like hey i
don't
necessarily emulate anybody i just wanna
i just want to be the best i can
possibly be and
you know he's he's he's a he's a again
his father having played in the league
he has really has really helped him i
think that gives guys a huge advantage
coming out of school
john thanks for the time man really
appreciate it love to do this as much as
you're willing up for doing and tell
pete i said hi uh that he looks great
with his shirt off oh yeah you know
i'll see i'll see if he's i'll see if
he's pissed at you okay
again i'm sensitive i'm sensitive i'm a
sensitive on-air talent man that's what
they call me at least in my face even
behind my back it's probably worse
but um
with good dk where you ran like dude
where they showed you running and where
he would be in the 40 compared to
yeah
let's just put it this way uh it didn't
um it didn't look good for me but that's
okay um
were you at the were you were you think
the 20
thank you for saying 20 my god i was at
the two i mean you know
but we did the the network did ha try to
uh match it up with me running as he was
running down buddha baker too you know
and uh that was unfortunate that was
unfortunate for me as well but it's all
good because like i said i can't get
enough of that guy man i just cannot get
enough of dk metcalf and uh i'm gonna
stop talking about it because he's
[ __ ] because somebody might take him
in my fantasy partner he partners up he
he partners up with one of the most
underrated players football league too
and tyler tyler lockett and and uh you
know tyler's such a quiet dude you know
it's amazing that
you know it was a big re-sign for us
this year to extend him so anyway i hope
you're feeling better rich thanks john i
really appreciate you that sentiment and
this phone call you take care you'll be
well all right take care john schneider
evp gm
seattle seahawks hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here